what is up there reject nation we are
there
to watch gravity falls today episode
four is season one hey if you could hit
that like button that'd be cool
subscribing click the notification
button notify my reaction for the next
one is up we got christmas coming so we
might miss next weeks depending on how
the schedule is looking just as a little
heads up thanks to the boys of prepper
for helping set down these highlights i
also would like to say thank you to all
who join our patreon page and become
how'd you call it john
super rejects superior superjects there
you go
cover a bunch of shows over there as
well same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included
i'm ready to watch this now
for tonight's final illusion we have the
incredible sack of mystery when you put
your money in it mysteriously disappears
oh of course that makes perfect is that
a nice man
got to try that are you completely
miserable yes
then you need to meet
he's a psychic
so don't waste your time with other
so-called
men of mystery
oh no oh
gideon's tend up telepathy boy no cody's
accepted car i've always loved you but
i've never had the guts to say
ever since that monster gideon rolled
into town i've had nothing but trouble
[Music]
i gideon a good silly rivalry loud under
that gideon's roof do tents have roofs i
think we just found our loophole
literally
she'll come down soon
i missed the lineup you were talking
over important line of dialogue i'm
gonna miss out on the entire mythos of
the show now the master of talking over
important lines of dialogue i'm gonna
not react at all for the rest of this
i'm just going to make it harder to edit
this intently can i say don't react i
said don't talk over important lines of
dialogue yeah i know i'm just over
compensating now you got to learn to
listen
right up there folks put your money in
gideon's psychic sack only once
that makes perfect sense
i'm doing john things are talking
my favorite kind of reaction
hello america my name is lil gideon oh
god
oh oh yeah
i predict you will soon i'll say
oh
[Music]
i can't see
what others can't see
it ain't some such a trick it's innate
ability
oh no
i'll read your mind if i'm able
[Applause]
something tells me your name mabel how
do you do that
thank you
you people are the real miracles
at the end of the show
[Laughter]
and did you see his hair it was like
whoosh you're too easily impressed yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh oh he's got a crush he's three tall
men in a suit when i saw you in the
audience i said to myself now there's a
kindred spirit someone who appreciates
the sparkly things in life that's
totally me
enchanting
i don't know how a lemon so sour could
be related to a peach so sweet get in
[Music]
oh my
wowza mabel i don't trust anyone whose
hair is bigger than their head i'll
leave him alone you never want to do
girly stuff with me you and sue's get to
do boy stuff all the time what do you
mean hey dude you ready to blow up these
hot dogs in the microwave one by one
i did that with a cd once don't try it
people i've never felt this close with
anyone so so close what's your game well
you do me the honor of going on a date
with me a playdate a shopping date uh-uh
it'll just be one little date i swear my
lucky bolo tie uh
okay
then i guess mabel pines you have made
me the happiest boy in the world are you
sniffing my hair so here's a boy and not
a man
well people have a hard time saying
hello to me
ah mr gideon the feet on the table an
excellent choice
everybody's talking about gideon and
mabel's big date tonight what that
little shyster is dating my great niece
i wonder what the new name will be for
the power couple uh-huh me billion getty
abel
it bellion
i told her not to yeah well it ends
tonight i'm going right down to that
little skunk's house yeah is he an adult
that's that was the sense i got but i i
guess not out of the way bud i'm looking
for gideon well i haven't seen the boy
around but since you're here
you you simply must come in for coffee
oh
i hear your niece and my gideon are well
they're singing in harmony lately so to
speak uh yeah and i'm against it
man
i see it as a fantastic business
opportunity yes the mystery shack and
the tent of telepathy we've been at each
other's throats for far too lo let me
get there eddie
this is our big chance to brush aside
our rivalry and pool our collective
prophets you see
i'm listening
merge the families mabel will you
accompany gideon
thursday
full of your does
i'm sorry but i'm gonna have to say i'm
on the edge of my seat this is gonna be
adorable if she says no i'll die from
sadness i can verify that that will
indeed happen
he asked me how to get and i didn't know
how to say no like this no it's not that
easy dipper and i do like gideon as a
friend slash little sister
i just need to get things back to where
they used to be you know friends uh-oh
this will go well i mean i'm always
happy to hang out with a friend buddy
pal chum other word for friend pal i
always said pal uh mate how about
soulmate
wow
mabel come on it's not like you're gonna
have to marry gideon great news mabel
you have to marry gideon
it's all part of my long team gideon
plus i got this shirt ugh i am fat
[Music]
love yourself uncle stan we've got to
talk mabel isn't joining you tonight she
uh she doesn't want to see you anymore
she's uh she's kind of weirded out by
you no offense
so what you're saying
come between us
no
freak out or anything are you too late
of course not these things happen
how'd it go was he mad did he try to
read your mind with his psychic powers
don't worry mabel he's just a kid he
doesn't have any powers okay good
confirmed
you've just made the biggest mistake of
your
life you charles gleeful
i can buy and sell you old man
whoa fair enough
i can buy a sell you
oh what have you done
yellow toby determined gravity falls
gossiper oh hey man sorry for accusing
you of murder last week
4-1-2 gopher road tonight
got it
there now it's time to pay your end of
the bargain
chandra jimenez's phone number bless you
will get in
creepers and gravity falls
[Music]
[Laughter]
i told you she's not into you liar you
turned her against me
she was my big dublin are you okay man
you've broken up with guys right oh yeah
russ durham eli hall maybe letting
dipper do it for me was a mistake gideon
deserves an honest breakup danny feldman
mark epstein i'm not sure i ever
actually broke up with him no wonder he
keeps calling me i think jeffrey
yeah
sure make sure
what the heck my todd give it back ha
not so powerful without this
use the magic
[Music]
listen gideon it's over i will never
ever date you yeah
no oh
the entire pines family have invoked my
fury you will all pay recompense for
your transgressions what you got like a
word a day calendar or something
sorry stan i have to side with gideon on
this one
oh
hey what are you gonna do without your
precious amulet oh you'll see boy
you'll see
[Music]
oh he's got more of his how about now
almost
and
there
[Music]
cool
[Laughter]
does that actually worked it might
in some way you live your best life suze
you're all fired
ah young love
young love there's a lot of that on the
show i remember
experiencing none of that when i was
younger
didn't have young love
i think
i did date someone but nothing ever is
that thing like leave me my girlfriend
she didn't even like hold hands yeah you
know i mean and you didn't like you know
do things together over long swaths of
time
yeah in fact i
heavily ignored the [ __ ] out of her
but that's a surefire sign to them that
you that you liked her i don't remember
calling it off oh yes we might as well
be together yeah that's right you're
probably married by now you should check
yeah interesting stuff
it seems like this was a setup for him
to return
it certainly seemed like that by the end
of it yeah
because so like there are funny bits in
here for sure there are bits that
definitely got to me but when you had a
setup like this i was a little bit let
down by uh how it progressed and high
hopes walking into this one guys
big expectations
you all you guys raved about it this
20-minute kids animated show yeah better
trounce every other drama i've watched
this week watch promos and trailers for
this it was no it was because i thought
it had cool setups you know you have
stan with this competitor and i like the
bit like the bits worked for me but i
think this show works best when it's
kind of complemented by the actual
immediate plot at hand
that i thought would go more extreme
like i don't know about extreme but just
do a little bit more with what they were
doing like i like the escalating bits of
just how elaborate um
gideon has like just access to the most
insane things for over romanticism and
it's like cheesy cordy obnoxious
uh like i enjoyed that stuff
and
i like i liked stan becoming team gideon
halfway through
like those little moments were really
fun and uh like where they teetered on
with gideon's obsession
it was more that it like i thought they
could have done more with the i thought
they would have had more fun with the
whole gideon versus stan
and then you know they're teasing the
amulet that he has and like the powers
that he can do
they're teasing a lot and this show
pretty much has been like funny setup
concepts
and then have the mystical supernatural
angle to it and they have something
really neat that i thought they were
going to do something more with but all
i did was like kind of move some stuff
around yeah and you would see like a
greater breadth of yeah mystical magic
power and and the true sinister
potential that gideon has to unleash you
know havoc upon the zone yeah and like
what makes him like truly appealing or
or what's like he has a whole book of
things that he can actually
pull from so i thought they might do a
little bit more of that or his
antagonistic side towards uh dipper as
that happened it just seemed like they
were
they were changing plots introducing
stuff but it sort of just became a
a thing without magic so it kind of was
just a predictable beat of how things
would go with them and and i wish they i
found myself going oh i thought you guys
would i really kept feeling like there
would be more to this there would be
more to oh he's against dipper oh he
that he has magic
it just kind of didn't do much so i feel
like when he does come back that's when
this will be rewarding but for this
episode it's like
that's the only one i walked away from
going
okay i really just kept feeling like
they should have done
almost everything they were doing i felt
like they could have done more plot wise
but but i mean if the main thing is
you're here to show up to laugh at some
bits i mean yeah there are some really
funny bits uh throughout this whole
episode from beginning to end there's no
denying that
uh but i do crave that a little bit of
extra nuance which makes the comedy
and uh really shine yeah i'm curious to
see as we progress further how the show
sort of does its thing because this
definitely did feel
like the setup to something that i'm not
sure when we'll see later but i just
imagine we will at some point see him
recurring
yeah at some point and so yeah i was
like you can't go to the full extent of
that but even so i feel like you could
have done like it seemed yeah quite
straightforward especially once you get
to the true reveal and i feel like we
said this last week was sort of i
appreciate
the commitment to certain elements of
the storyline that they've chosen uh but
i think that in this case and to to a
certain extent in in previous episodes
like yeah if there was
a slightly different
balance of that like
bonkers quality like you know there's so
many really cool and fun and mysterious
elements or like little nods to things
like when they go to the club and it's
out of twin peaks or just you the
different potential for creatures and
characters and like there's always this
sort of
fun
and
you know
cryptid crawling you know eerie sort of
life that's always around them and so i
guess there's always an expectation
then for things to get like truly out
there and stuff like that and yeah like
for
uh the magical amulet it seemed like it
was yeah it's just pretty much like
levitation
yeah just remove some stuff yeah yeah
and i thought it was going to reveal
something like he uses stuff to
manipulate people into liking him or
being subservient to him in some way or
something about his you know telepathy
act is is more sinister than it appears
at first like you know i
i in one breath appreciate the
quirkiness of like his dad who he lives
with i guess it's just like super
friendly and good-natured and he is
feigning that flavor and is super
entitled and stuff like that but even
that like
you know there could be a reveal later
but even that was just like more
straightforward than i was expecting
like oh
okay i guess this dad is just sort of
oblivious and uh gideon does what he
wants
but yeah
yeah
and i i guess i'm fascinated too because
i know this show is aimed at uh slightly
again like tweens and young teenagers so
i feel like they're slightly more
elevated or more
verging on teen or adult theme because
you know it's like people are always
trying to date mabel and and this time i
know we were going back and forth like
is this character supposed to be a kid
uh and because he was dance competition
too and i thought it was just a little
person yeah i thought it was just like
because yeah there's a cartoony
portrayal of like a highway preacher
yeah and and so in a breath i'm like i
appreciate that we can do these more
like yeah you know for somebody in the
sage bracket if you're a girl watching
the show you know like you'll probably
have to deal with the boy who's kind of
obsessed with you at some point in time
uh but i i find it and if you haven't
i'm sorry because it's great it's the
best you should be flattered i've heard
too when you're an adult that's even
better oh definitely you're like someone
a woman on the internet even gets so
much it gets so much better and dudes
never give up all right just persistence
wears down resistance they send you
pictures before even sending you
messages
with words in them so yeah it just gets
better from there gideon playbook
but uh
it's funny in this context my initial
response to that is sort of like
i'm almost a little creeped by the way
so many people are like leering on mabel
but at the same time it's it's like an
actual facet of life that's kind of
creepy so gravity falls is about
portraying life that's right and the
creepiness therein but through complex
allegorical applications of magic mumbo
jumbo in real life interpersonal
conflict
yeah it seems like what they've done
with him is it's setting up something
bigger to come yeah or something more
rewarding or more
that goes truly bonkers yeah like the
first i mean this the show starts off
with something pretty big
you know like a date with is it a zombie
investigating it then it becomes gnomes
and then the gnome certains are like a
megazord of is that like it's it really
goes there
and then they introduce other concepts
and the other ones that i thought were
weren't as i liked the second episode a
lot because
uh yeah it had like the uncovering of uh
of uh you know uh
what's the terminology for things like
that loch dis monster bigfoot yeah it
was a god it's some made up yeah but
what's like what's the category of that
oh like a big old sea monster
yeah well like people could put in that
oh crypto crypto zoological
cryptocurrency cryptids yeah cryptids so
yeah like having that
that in there and then but it was also
really backed with the
stand scene that he really cares about
them and yeah and the third episode had
that
um murder mysteries and this element
yeah then the wax figures coming to life
you know like that that stuff's cool and
then it has like the melting and stuff
then here it was like i feel like i've
seen this thing in other sitcoms and
stuff before other shows isn't
everything it didn't feel
like
pure gravity falls to not that i know
this show
fourth [ __ ] episode so i don't know
this show i'm just saying that there was
there was a
a thing over here that was like ah after
seeing three episodes so far i'm already
under the impression that they would
have done more yeah i was expecting
something a bit kookier and this was a
little more straightforward yeah than i
had expected but it's still fun
yeah i mean when it's when it's just
aiming to be a comedy like that works
yeah you know but i think what makes
what probably makes this show special
for a lot of people
and for what stands out to me is that
it's not just funny that there's a
little bit more additional stuff whether
that's at the forefront or more
subconscious yeah you know there's like
the actual heart but then when they want
to go into being like eerie sci-fi or
something they commit a bit more than
your average like kid's cartoon yeah
yeah yeah but i do i mean i like
i like uh satire of narcissism a lot
yeah i'm a big fan of that so like him
instead of turning around stroking a cat
he's like stroking a little doll of him
so like that's that's that's really
funny to me
that's one of my fave i feel like there
are things in animation everybody has
some kind of weird animation tick that
particularly tickles them and that's one
for me of like any time a character has
a miniature version of themselves yeah
especially larger kick out of that and
two i mean the voice acting i thought uh
for gideon especially was
appropriately like
icky but amusing yeah yeah it's so
trickly
all right guys we're quitting the show
now done so now i know what happens when
you just when you're not a big fan of an
episode people go find unsubscribing
yeah like what i like
unanimous praise unanimous praise all
around until the final episode really
let it all out because i don't need to
keep you guys watching
[Laughter]
so always approach every positive review
with suspicion
up until we're at the finale
you'll know all
all will be revealed all right guys
thanks so much for being here still
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button and we'll catch you guys soon